something like seven million years ago
there was nothing like a human on earth
there was not even a pre human standing
upright
there were simply great apes very much
like the ones that live with us today
[Music]
I was crossing the river at dawn it was
just getting light and I was jumping
from stone to stone to try not to get my
boots wet as I crossed this broad stream
and in the middle I pause then I looked
down the stream just to kind of you know
woke up and down the stream just to
check out the view and when I looked
downstream just about 20 meters away
from me maybe 30 meters away from me at
the most there was a big male or onit on
and he hadn't seen me because he was
doing the same thing as me he was going
the other direction trying to cross the
river without getting his feet wet I
just was so struck by the fact that what
he was doing was so similar to what I
was just doing and I just felt like you
know to a sort of passing the morning
dawn there
[Music]
we usually have to get up really early
so maybe 3:30 in the morning wake up and
then get ready and we really need to be
at the run upon Ness by 5:00 a.m. when
they wake up so that means you ready and
then hiking could be up to an hour and
the rain forest in the dark using our
headlamp to the nest one of the things
that makes a heart is actually finding
them they're primarily solitary and so
it actually takes a long time to find
them they can they can go outside of our
of our study area it may take us like a
week of search days of their person days
to actually find their aunt on
it's not realistic to just what hunter
force myself and go find a neurotic on
the photograph it's not gonna happen so
I'm always teaming up with a research
team that are already trusting followed
in Toronto
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the whole world
ironic on only lived in one area
two big islands of Sumatra and Borneo in
Southeast Asia and within those islands
of course they only lives in the
remaining good areas of rainforest one
of those is a national park called zoom
polymers where I've been working for for
twenty years with my wife Sheryl and
that's where she has a long-term runtime
project our site is deep in the interior
of that National Park and it comprises
the eight different habitats
[Music]
tamo national in american prostitute ama
national Tolan capti indonesia Canisius
Karen Tama national goon voluma della
paura Hindu suppose away an eternity
Diprivan kawasan inwardly a certificate
are ya guru paul national park is this
huge area over a hundred thousand
hectares in size and challenge County
Research Station which is where we've
carried out most of the proton research
academic pound is only two thousand
hectares and these are on atoms the
wrong times we study at chellah Ponte
they don't necessarily stay within those
two thousand hectares all the time so my
goal was to stay with these wrong tones
for five days sometimes up to ten days
in a row over the course of an entire
year by staying with them for these long
periods I was also able to document
really unique behaviors that haven't
been captured before
so before I studied biology and
anthropology in college I really had no
idea that other species had culture
besides humans and so when I saw these
cultural traditions in Iran for the
first time it was sort of a really big
sight to behold it was my first day and
I was out early in the morning to go to
Cho that's nest and when I got there I
had never seen her on the town in the
wild not even in the zoo and I was under
his tree waiting for him to wake up
sometime around 5:30 in the morning
first thing he did was he let out this
really loud long call right above me
[Music]
it was a very powerful experience it was
not a sound that I for anything like it
to meet culture is such a human element
and to see in other species is really
fascinating culture means so much to
humans so almost everything we do is
cultural both with feeding traditions
and with social traditions you see
things that are inherited from mother to
child for sometimes adopted from friend
to friend that show that behavior has
got this wonderful flexibility
adaptability that is so much of a
characteristic of humans and seen in the
great apes
[Music]
so around towns do this vocalization
called kiss squeaking it's done by
cursing their lips and making a kissing
sound like like a roll much louder
vocalization this week is a not a threat
sound that they make when they actually
meet an unfamiliar onit on they also do
it to people sometimes including pollen
they do this using leaves they grab some
liens they bring it up to their mouth
they do this kiss squeak and then they
throw the leaves out at other field
sites they may not use the leaves at all
this is an example of a local custom
that's found in that area similar to the
way people greet each other differently
in different countries maybe in some
place you know people shake hands
another place they bow so wrong times
are also showing these interesting
cultural variations between sites
[Music]
I've always been fascinated understand
you know why we're human what makes us
human
you know we had so many kinds of humans
in the past and different kinds of
bipedal Apes you know Oscar put the
scenes and we had some that went extinct
and some that didn't and then involved
into human so you know why is that you
know why did some population of also put
the scenes eventually evolved into the
Homo genus I think that the human
species is incredibly fortunate to have
in orangutans and the other great apes
gorillas and bonobos and chimpanzees
representatives of what we came from we
still share of varying a large
percentage of our DNA with maybe around
97% orangutans survived one window into
understanding human evolution
[Music]
there's different ways that bronze ons
make umbrellas one way is they just
break off an entire branch and sort of
modify this branch to make an umbrella
other times they pull the entire branch
towards then make a little roof over the
head
some were on a tongue when they're
making a nest and it's still raining
really hard they would actually make a
big roof over their nests they can put
together a bunch of branches and leaves
and sort of weave hovering and that's a
really effective way for them to stay
dry while they're sleeping
to all the great apes make this and
they're the only primate that makes nest
that's important because they have large
bodies and it's a way that they can
sleep in the trees where they're safer
from ground predators there seems to be
variation and kind of some subtleties of
nest building we heard some researchers
from another site describing that they
made a pillow to go in the nest and we
thought oh you know we've never seen
that right but we'd never have thought
about it like we just thought of making
a nest building a platform and lying
down and we never watched that closely
well once we heard these researchers and
other sites say that if they saw around
convicting a pillow we started watching
more carefully and then and then sure
enough like we noticed that there are
cons that good and pollen we're also
sometimes making a pillow it's putting
it down just as they plop down on top of
it and so as researchers you know learn
more and more about our own towns and
know what flushes to ask know what to
look for you know we're learning more
interesting things
it is so precious to be able to
understand our connection to the natural
world to have these other species to
give us lessons and remind us where we
come from
it makes us in some ways humble it also
makes us fascinated and yet we risk
losing them all newton guitar and render
it rock a paean young you can cover
stock arendelle a student of Turin green
de totora Trujillo energetically
mountain yam a sativa
every bit of course that's waah gnorga
Ron can't live anymore because it's
turning to alcohol plantation or burn
down is not good for our caste and
that's the main reason that number of
Ron towns have been declining
drastically over the last few decades
it's because of the huge amount of
forest in Borneo and Sumatra that have
been lost
in 2016 orangutan became critically
endangered they are in a very top level
of threatened category their numbers are
decreasing at a more rapid rate than we
had initially thought and they are in
need of immediate conservation action
it's gonna be a race against time to be
able to document what are the cultural
variation before they just disappear
forever
every lock on life is really important
they only have an average of the baby
about once every seven or eight years
the longest of birth spacing of any
mammal so with their slow rate of
reproduction a lot of dogs simply can't
sustain any kind of reduction in their
population like that over the long term
this century we could lose all of the
orangutans if it carries on the rate of
devastation in Borneo and Sumatra that's
been seen in the recent decades we stand
so much to gain and we stand so much to
lose
yes
you can't protect what you don't know we
can't all go to Borneo or Smosh or we
can't all go to the rainforest there but
we can bring the rainforest to people
through through a media coverage all
right first shot all that practice
yesterday you don't
[Music]
Oh murders every population is different
and the more we study them some more
different we realize they are
[Music]
when you see in Arakan I'm looking back
at you you can you know sense up there
is something there in those eyes you
know they're thinking it's hard to
imagine that we could just sort of
what's that goats name
you
[Music]